avant de commencer la séance du conseil
d'administration de l'établissement
public interdépartemental yvelines hauts
de seine un dernier hommage est rendu à
patrick devedjian
pierre bédier vice président et
président par intérim de le pays a par
la suite proposé la candidature de son
homologue georges siffredi président du
conseil départemental des hauts-de-seine
à la présidence de le pays
dès que j'ai su qu'il était candidat à
la succession de patrick devedjian de
prendre aussi sa succession un
établissement public interdépartemental
puisque c'était un accord qui avait été
passé avec patrick devedjan les
hauts-de-seine aller jusqu'en mars 2021
et après on discutera de tout ça change
qu'on espère un c'était ne pas avoir
discuté que la fusion soit faite sur 79
votants georges siffredi est élu à la
présidence de le pays à l'unanimité
pierre à bédié et lui aussi élu pour la
vice-présidence avec les membres du
bureau se succéder à patrick devedjian
qui était personnalité donc évident ça
vous met des responsables et
supplémentaire sur les épaules mais je
vois tout cela sereinement parce que
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été faites
et qu'avec le président bédié nous
entendons me très bien nous connaissons
depuis longtemps convaincu par l'apport
de la fusion yvelines hauts-de-seine le
président de le pays veut travailler en
étroite relation avec les yvelines
notamment sur le projet de la plate
forme d'établissements et services pour
personnes en situation de handicap
psychique ou atteintes d'autisme
pour l'instant sa liste peu en france
les parents sont obligés d'envoyer leurs
enfants d'aller vers l'étranger c'est ce
qu'on aura affaire au niveau des
autistes et ça c'est vraiment une
première et je crois que c'est
primordial les travaux commencent et on
est un exemple espérant en france et
qu'on va donner l'idée à beaucoup
d'autres de s'engager dans cette voie
l'ouverture de la plate forme est prévue
pour la fin de l'année
le prochain conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines
hauts-de-seine se déroulera le 15
décembre